[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi capita mai quando siete al
supermercato in fila alla cassa di
sbirciare nel carrello di chi vi precede
a me capita qualche volta è come fare
una piccola incursione nella vita di
quella persona quello che mettiamo nel
carrello dice molto di noi delle nostre
abitudini delle nostre preferenze delle
nostre scelte e ci lascia intuire anche
molto sul nostro impatto ambientale
quando facciamo la spesa mettiamo nel
carrello prodotti e cibi di cui
conosciamo il prezzo ma di cui raramente
conosciamo il costo ambientale ed etico
se conoscessimo davvero questi costi
cambierebbe il modo in cui facciamo i
nostri acquisti
se avessimo tutti gli strumenti per
decidere
cominceremo per esempio ad interrogarci
sul peso dei prodotti animali rispetto a
quelli vegetali orientandoci verso
questi ultimi eliminare dalla nostra
routine gli alimenti di derivazione
animale risulta essere un'ottima
strategia per ridurre al minimo il
nostro impatto sul pianeta
a dircelo sono studi di caratura e di
rilevanza internazionale che derivano
dal gruppo intergovernativo per il
cambiamento climatico
la fao l'università di oxford che nel
2018 pubblicato un report guidata dal
professor joseph pur che ha
letteralmente fatto il giro del mondo
da più parti ci viene detto che i
cambiamenti climatici non possono essere
arginati senza un cambiamento delle
nostre alimentazioni senza uno
spostamento verso un'alimentazione
vegetale per muoverci in questa
direzione quindi dobbiamo cominciare ad
immaginare il veganismo
come un'opportunità dobbiamo abbattere
alcuni pregiudizi su questa scelta di
vita e cominciare ad immaginarlo come
una vera possibilità di cambiamento ma
che cos'è il veganismo e chi sono questi
vegani di cui parlano tutti il veganismo
non è un regime alimentare è uno stile
di vita è una visione del mondo
il concretizzarsi di un interazione fra
gli esseri viventi non filtrato da alcun
tipo di superiorità l'uomo non è
superiore alle altre specie l'ovvia
conseguenza è quella di scegliere di non
mangiare animali di non consumare
derivati animali di non indossarli e di
non appoggiare alcuna operazioni di
sfruttamento
nonostante non sia una dieta alimentare
l'alimentazione è senz'altro una parte
consistente di questa scelta di vita e
di questo voglio parlare proverò a
rispondere a due delle affermazioni tipo
più diffuse quando si tratta di scelta
vegana la prima comprendo le tue ragioni
ma a me carne formaggi piacciono troppo
è una questione di gusti e non ci
rinuncerei questa affermazione in genere
fa leva sul concetto di gusto personale
in quanto tale non può essere messo in
discussione
ma siamo proprio sicuri che possiamo
concederci il lusso di immaginare il
cibo come una mera scelta personale
innocua e senza conseguenze
la risposta è no abbiamo invece una
grande responsabilità rispetto a ciò che
mettiamo nel piatto e abbiamo anche dati
molto precisi che ci aiutano a
quantificare l'impatto dei derivati
animali
secondo dati unesco per esempio per
produrre un solo chilo di carne di manzo
servono più di 15 mila 400 litri d'acqua
il che significa che per portare in
tavola una bistecca da 300 grammi
servono più di 4 mila 600 litri d'acqua
l'equivalente di 31 vasche da bagno
piene fino all'orlo
è come se io mi lavarsi i denti e poi
lasciasse aperto il rubinetto a massimo
flusso per le successive dieci ore
secondo la fao in oltre un quarto delle
terre emerse e occupato da allevamenti
campi agricoli per la produzione di
cereali e soia da destinare ai mangimi
per gli allevamenti impianti di
produzione e confezionamento
si tratta di una superficie pari ad
europa e africa
messi insieme e per fare spazio a queste
terre
a queste a questi impianti da immettere
nelle filiere della carne stiamo anche
distruggendo le foreste i principali
polmoni verdi della terra in grado di
assorbire co2
stiamo perdendo le foreste ad un ritmo
dell'equivalente di un campo da calcio
ogni minuto
questi dati quindi ci dicono che non
solo ciò che mettiamo nel piatto non è
senza conseguenze ma che ha
ripercussioni su tutto il sistema terra
esiste poi una seconda obiezione alla
scelta vegan ed è comprendo queste tue
ragioni ma onestamente diventare vegani
mi sembra un po estremo per rispondere a
questa affermazione vi racconto la mia
storia il mio percorso di come sono
diventata vegana dieci anni fa mi
trovavo a barcellona
e mentre camminavo per le vie della
città mi sono imbattuta in un gruppo di
attivisti vegani che mostravano le
dinamiche di produzione della carne
ciò che mi colpì e che la loro protesta
era silenziosa non dicevano una parola
ma in un silenzio raggelante
proiettavano sul muro esterno di una
casa le immagini dell'interno di un
mattatoio erano immagini di una routine
giornaliera di lavorazione ordinaria
amministrazione
si direbbe ma di fatto era un bagno di
sangue
la mia prima reazione a quelle immagini
respingenti fu quella di voltarmi
dall'altra parte per non guardare ma
nonostante io abbia visto quelle
immagini solo per pochi secondi
un'idea potente ha messo radici nella
mia mente e non mi ha più abbandonato
c'è troppo che non conosciamo rispetto
al modo in cui il cibo arriva sulle
nostre tavole rispetto perfino a ciò che
consideriamo cibo
da quel momento ho cominciato una mia
personale rivoluzione eliminando
gradualmente carne pesce latte e tutti i
derivati animali ma perchè vi racconto
questa storia e per che tiro in ballo
anche l'aspetto etico della produzione
di derivati animali in fondo alcuni
potrebbero pensare che le istanze di
natura etica hanno poco a che vedere con
il cambiamento climatico
invece no ne parlo perché in questa
storia c'è la radice del problema e il
problema è il nostro ruolo in un sistema
di produzione consumo che legittima lo
sfruttamento degli animali e delle
risorse naturali la concezione che
abbiamo introiettato di essere in cima
ad una piramide di predominio e non
all'interno di un ecosistema è il motivo
per cui oggi ci troviamo qui ad arginare
anche questa crisi climatica è l'idea
che tutto sia a nostro uso e consumo che
ci ha condotti qui ad affacciarci sul
baratro con un countdown thing tombe la
chiave è proprio quella di smantellare
l'idea di essere all'apice di una
piramide di predominio e cominciare ad
immaginarci invece come parte di un
sistema complesso all'interno non
all'apice quindi per tornare alla
domanda iniziale essere vegani a una
scelta estrema
no è una prospettiva dall'acqua
possiamo vedere la realtà con occhi
nuovi e dalla quale possiamo ripartire
ogni minuto nel mondo vengono macellati
300 mila animali sono 4.576 ogni secondo
lo ripeto in un secondo 4.756 questo
estremo e non necessario noi facciamo
nascere miliardi di animali per
immetterli nelle filiere della carne
ridurre riduciamo esseri senzienti in
beni di consumo
questo è estremo è dura accettare questi
aspetti toccano delle corde molto
profonde vanno a toccare anche
tradizioni alimentari consolidate e per
questo danno anche fastidio lo so ma il
punto è proprio questo dobbiamo capire
come ricollocarci nel sistema naturale
come generare quella nuova normalità di
cui tutti parlano
se ci orienta assimo verso
un'alimentazione vegetale riprendendo le
parole dello scienziato joseph pur
dell'università di oxford noi metteremo
in campo uno dei sistemi più efficaci
per arginare la crisi climatica e non
solo in termini di emissioni di co2 ma
anche in termini di acidificazione del
suolo eutrofizzazione delle acque uso
delle terre uso dell'acqua
passiamo all'azione dunque e da dove
cominciamo
beh innanzitutto dalla consapevolezza
che ad un livello personale noi possiamo
incidere molto possiamo decidere di
escludere i derivati animali dalla
nostra alimentazione scegliere con cura
cosa mettere nel carrello e cosa portare
nelle nostre tavole
possiamo decidere di riformulare il
concetto di tradizione culinaria
smantellando il dogma del abbiamo sempre
mangiato così magari rivalutando
l'enorme patrimonio vegetale della
nostra terra
le nostre scelte alimentari tracciano
una specifica direzione ed esprimono
anche una volontà
molto precisa e di questo dobbiamo
essere consapevoli
quindi la prossima volta che al
supermercato in fila alla cassa magari
annoiati andremo a sbirciare il carrello
del nostro vicino riguarderemo il nostro
prendiamoci qualche minuto per pensare a
cosa stiamo portando sulle nostre tavole
nelle nostre case noi possiamo guidare
il sistema verso una maggiore
sostenibilità e per farlo dobbiamo dare
una svolta vegetale al nostro sistema
alimentare per gli animali in primis per
l'impatto ambientale e quindi anche per
noi stessi
grazie
[Applauso]